et voici le sommaire de ce 19 octobre la
fin de la production des voitures
thermiques et programmées pour 2035 en
Europe mais au Mondial de l'Automobile
tous les constructeurs affichent des
objectifs plus ambitieux la mobilité
tout électrique est-elle forcément une
bonne idée l'Europe était en train
d'offrir son marché aux marques
chinoises en en débat dans une minute
sommes-nous entrer dans le troisième âge
nucléaire une nouvelle aire de
rhétorique désinhibée comme en Russie et
de course à la bombe comme en Corée du
Nord
le bouton nucléaire est toujours sur mon
bureau les États-Unis doivent prendre
conscience que ce n'est pas du chantage
mais la réalité
ou une menace l'Iran veut aussi sa bombe
nucléaire et la menace d'armes tactique
utilisée contre l'Ukraine enfle pour
faire la part entre peur légitime et
gesticulation ne ratez pas l'analyse de
nos experts sur ce thème tout à l'heure
mais d'abord donc cette voiture
électrique lancée à pleine vitesse sur
nos routes européennes au volant
américain
Renaud dévoile sa nouvelle 4L 100%
électrique les voitures électriques sont
les stars du salon de l'automobile ou le
chef de l'État a rappelé les objectifs
de la France produire 2 millions de
véhicules électriques par an en 2030 et
100% de voitures électriques en 2035 il
y a 5 ans on en parlait hier avec les
constructeurs 1% du marché des ventes
c'était l'électrique aujourd'hui c'est
10% on a multiplié par 1050 l'objectif
c'est que à la fin de ce quinquennat on
soit à 30% du marché des ventes donc en
flux pour inciter les Français à passer
à l'électrique le gouvernement poursuit
le déploiement des bornes de
rechargement le pays en compte un
million 100000 et on construit chaque
mois 3000 supplémentaires selon Emmanuel
Macron le bonus écologique pour l'achat
d'une voiture électrique passe de 6 à
7000 euros pour les ménages les plus
modestes le prix de l'électrique reste
un obstacle de taille aujourd'hui une
voiture électrique coûte beaucoup plus
cher qu'une thermique les foyers qui
seront éligibles à cette augmentation de
la prime non de toute manière pas les
moyens d'acheter une voiture électrique
neuve
donc je vois ça plutôt comme un effet
d'annonce et j'ai du mal à imaginer que
ça puisse booster les ventes de voitures
électriques pour moi il faut vraiment
que le produit soit abordable et
compétent technologiquement pour qu'il y
ait un vrai bout au niveau des voitures
électriques et des ventes pour cela il
faut notamment faire baisser le prix des
batteries la France comptera bientôt
trois usines de fabrication de batterie
dans les hauts de France l'ambition du
gouvernement crée une filière 100%
française face à la concurrence
asiatique
le premier débat de ce sens public avec
Daniel Attias bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur à centrale Supélec
Université Paris Saclay et vous publiez
auteur de la révolution de l'automobile
vers un nouveau paradigme de
l'électromobilité aux éditions Springer
Mathieu flonau bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes historien des mobilités enseignant
chercheur à l'Université Paris impensé
en Sorbonne votre livre en tous sens
circulé partagé sécurisé une histoire
des équipements de la route publié aux
éditions
loubatier Frédéric dans et bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste spécialiste des
questions d'environnement alors vous
publiez je vais choisir rencontre avec
les écolos remarquables de la chaux chez
de la chaux et Nestlé voilà il y a bien
sûr de mobilité non remarquable et
Mathieu croissanto il t'aurait politique
bonsoir bonsoir Mathieu je rappelle ce
chiffre alors il est un peu plus élevé
que celui donné par le Président de la
République lorsqu'il était au Mondial de
l'Auto lundi 12,7% des voitures vendues
en France en 2022 sont des véhicules
électriques et effectivement c'était 1%
en 2017 dan
viendra c'est pas c'est évidemment pas
un hasard Mathieu flonot est-ce que
avant évidemment le point de départ
c'est cette décision dont on a beaucoup
parlé de l'Union européenne donc
interdire la vente de et la production
de véhicules thermiques à partir de 2035
ça veut dire qu'on ne pourra plus
acheter de véhicules neuf que à mobilité
électrique est-ce qu'on a mesuré toutes
les conséquences de cette décision je
pense le truc très clairement que nous
c'est-à-dire que ce mondial n'est pas si
spectaculaire que cela ce Mondial
intervient dans un moment de Chris grave
de la filière automobile la robustesse
du système électrique et du nouveau
régime routier elle est encore approuvée
il y a énormément d'hypothèques sur
précisément le prix de la nouvelle
énergie qui sera disponible
les Chinois vous l'avez dit perçoivent
ce Mondial aussi comme une forme de
tapis rouge qui a été dit par Calo
stabares il y a d'énormes tensions dans
le patron de stellantis qui parle vrai
sur le sujet et qui dit bien que
effectivement il ne faudra pas aussi
dans quelques années revenir en arrière
en disant vous les constructeurs vous
avez fait des mauvais choix donc il y a
énormément d'hypothèques autour d'une
transition qui dont les coûts en tout
cas ont été largement sous-estimés on
aura l'occasion de revenir très
probablement Frédéric est-ce qu'on a le
choix si on veut réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre est-ce qu'on a
un autre choix que celui de basculer
vers finalement la mobilité parce que
c'est pas seulement la voiture la
mobilité électrique sans doute pas à
terme non après dans l'état actuel des
choses je rejoins ce que ce que vous
venez de dire la voiture électrique est
pas écologique la voiture électrique
n'est pas moins de CO2 qu'un véhicule
diesel parce que ces produits à
l'étranger donc c'est pas produit en
France parce que dans le monde là où les
véhicules électriques roulent
l'électricité et produite à partir de
charbon donc pour l'instant c'est pas du
tout une solution ça pourrait le devenir
si ces véhicules électriques étaient
produits en France si ces véhicules
étaient électriques étaient beaucoup
moins lourds et oui beaucoup moins lourd
que les que les véhicules pardon
électrique d'aujourd'hui qui prennent le
même travers que les véhicules diesel
c'est-à-dire qu'on pourrait aujourd'hui
rouler dans des toutes petites voitures
contenu des améliorations technologiques
et en fait on se retrouve avec des
véhicules de plus en plus gros de plus
en plus lourds a fortiori avec des
véhicules électriques qui pour avaler
leurs dettes carbone doivent rouler à
laisser 15000 km en plus qu'un véhicule
diesel quand c'est une petite voiture
type Zoé mais quand c'est un véhicule
électrique moyen très lourd qui peut
faire jusqu'à 2 tonnes 5 c'est au moins
100000 km donc pour l'instant on n'y est
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
peut-être qu'on y sera demain et si on y
est demain en termes de production se
posera la question de l'origine de
l'électricité et là comme la transition
énergétique d'une vaste blague en France
comment va-t-on produire l'électricité
de façon verte dans 10 ans j'en sais
rien évidemment si on roule à
l'électrique il faut mieux que ce soit
de l'électrique qui soit on va dire un
mix énergétique nucléaire renouvelable
que des centrales à charbon mais si
seulement si et seulement si on a
modifié notre usage de la voiture si on
va en parler parce que c'est tout la
civilisation de la voiture finalement
qui est en question et c'est pour ça que
ce débat est passionnant
[Musique]
entre les pays constructeurs
d'automobiles comme la France et puis
les autres qui étaient déjà passés à
d'autres systèmes de mobilité ou qui
avait une industrie automobile moins
forte mais le paradoxe c'est qu'un
certain nombre de politiques aujourd'hui
y compris au gouvernement se demande si
on n'est pas allé en fait un peu vite en
besogne pendant ces 7 ans pourquoi mais
parce que cette décision on en a
commencé à en toucher un peu pose des
questions qu'on peut encore été résolu
tout simplement c'est une décision qui a
été prise un peu parfois sans études
d'impact parfois a priori sans sans
imaginer ce que sera l'après alors pour
le climat et la qualité de l'air on peut
dire que c'est bon même si Frédéric nous
dit que ça sera pas bon ça dépend du
poids de la voiture mais c'est moins
évident pour le consommateur parce que
les voitures électriques vous l'avez dit
sont chères très cher même et que même
les primes conséquentes ne font pas
baisser l'addition au niveau des
voitures thermiques par ailleurs et
quand même des trucs tous les
propriétaires enfin parmi les
propriétaires de voiture il y en a
beaucoup qui financent l'achat de la
nouvelle par la revente de la précédente
en tout cas là ça sera pas possible
puisque qui va racheter des voitures
thermiques personne est-ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour les ruraux pas si
sûr non plus parce que la voiture
électrique compte tenu de de son
développement actuelle de son autonomie
c'est parfait pour les villes pour les
campagnes est-ce qu'il y aura cette
bande partout alors on a vu dans votre
portage ça se construisait mais c'est
encore une autre question pour les
salariés il y a un risque quand même
évident sur l'emploi que vont devenir
les salariés de l'industrie automobile
sous-traitants compris
là est-ce qu'il y a une étude d'impact
réel sérieuse qui a été faite est-ce
qu'on sait voilà on connaitre les
plateformes en plus de construction de
voiture électrique sont moins moins
d'oeuvre les voitures thermiques pour
les industriels français aussi vous
l'avez dit parce que beaucoup alors déjà
c'est quand même été on les aflingué
beaucoup avait misé sur une technologie
hybride pas de peau les hybrides c'est
interdit comme les thermiques à partir
2035 c'est un choix qui aurait pu être
interrogé aussi mais la France a perdu
sur ce point et donc du coup ils vont
subir de plein fouet ceux qui ont la
technologie c'est les Chinois et pour le
coup ils étaient très mauvais en voiture
thermique très mauvais en voiture
hybride parce qu'il peut l'est beaucoup
et puis enfin pour l'État aussi coûte
des recettes fiscales liées au carburant
c'est une vraie question c'est pas rien
c'est pas une bagatelle c'est 45
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui à peu près
les recettes fiscales des carburants
est-ce que tout ça cache une future taxe
sur la consommation électrique des
voitures si c'est le cas il faut le dire
parce qu'on aurait pu en discuter avant
et puis enfin la facture énergétique
Frédéric en a touché un mot bref il
reste 13 ans pour y avancer pour avancer
pour essayer de tenter de répondre à ces
questions et de pour le coup c'est 13
ans ça paraît un délai bien court les 7
ans c'était peut-être un peu long mais
les Fraisans c'est c'est un délai un peu
court Daniel Attias tiens je vais
démarrer sur les bornes électriques
allez parce qu'il y a plein de plein de
fil à tirer là dans ce débat est-ce que
ça construit ça se le maillage progresse
mais est-ce qu'on est toujours en retard
par rapport aux objectifs qu'on s'était
fixés un petit peu
insuffisant surtout dans les centres
urbains parce que finalement on a
beaucoup sur les autoroutes faut pas
négliger aussi que les constructeurs ont
fait je pense à Tesla le choix
d'implanter ses propres bornes alors là
il y en a partout ça y a pas de souci
mais quand on a pas une Tesla qu'on a
une voiture une petite citadine
électrique ou une voiture un peu plus
conséquente ça devient plus compliqué
hein ils sont urbain moi j'ai moi-même
une voiture électrique c'est très
difficile il est parkings sont peu
équipés pour des voitures électriques il
y a très peu de place on a trois quatre
5 places ce qui est absolument ridicule
dans les dans les villes il y en a pas
pratiquement pas et nous n'avons pas
encore imposé au syndic de copropriété
des bornes dans chaque immeuble oui
juste une question sur la Tesla parce
que moi je suis pas du tout un
spécialiste il y a pas une énorme
déchargeur ça va faire comme pour les
téléphones portables chacun parle dans
son coin chaque marque a son chargeur
parce que quand on parle de bord il faut
parler des bornes lentes ou rapides
alors il se trouve que Tesla a mis en
place pratiquement partout des bornes
très rapides et en fait c'est vrai que
quand vous arrivez à charger en 18
minutes pour environ 500 600 km on va
dire 500 en moyenne c'est ça marche avec
une voiture d'une autre marque c'est
borne ou
pasteur qui a effectivement mis en place
ses propres bandes dans 20 ans dira on
peut peut-être harmoniser les chargeurs
comme elle l'a fait pour les téléphones
mobiles je pense qu'on va le faire il y
a une discussion en cours qui est claire
parce que ça crée des inégalités ça crée
des accès effectivement à l'électricité
qui qui n'est pas égale c'est c'est tout
à fait puisque on parle finalement de de
la capacité de recharge est-ce que le
réseau RTE c'est à dire le réseau de
transport d'électricité est-ce qu'il est
adapté il faut imaginer imaginons on est
en 2035 on a tous enfin pas tous parce
qu'il y aura des gens qui pourront
continuer de rouler avec leur vieux
modèle thermique mais il y a des
millions de voitures électriques en
France on va tous recharger entre 18h et
20h pas grosso modo quand on rentre du
bureau on tient à la charge ou pas non
non non parce que ça créera ça
augmentera les pics de consommation et
qu'est-ce qu'il y aura derrière pour
soutenir ces pics si demain en plus on a
des moyens de production certes travers
mais très intermittent si demain on n'a
pas des moyens lourds comme les
centrales nucléaires et si tout le monde
vient recharger en même temps sur des
bornes de recharge rapide bon j'y crois
pas beaucoup qui va pouvoir soutenir
cette hausse de l'attention c'est
forcément des moyens de production qu'on
peut mettre en marche très rapidement
c'est du gaz et du charbon après on
touche bien là notre imaginaire pourquoi
demain on irait recharger la voiture
aussi vite qu'on va faire le plein
d'essence en fait la question est là si
demain on accepte de recharger sa
voiture pendant qu'on dort
auto électrique c'est pas une façon de
garder ce qui est notre modèle de
société c'est-à-dire le modèle de
société construit autour de la voiture
depuis des décennies pour ne pas dire
plus votre question appelle plusieurs
réponses d'abord on ne changera pas un
système contre un autre c'est une
évidence c'est-à-dire que tout ce qu'on
vient de dire s'oriente vers une
mobilité dégradée il faut l'annoncer
mais militer dégradé est plus cher
première chose deuxième chose quand même
dans la continuité historique que vous
venez de soulever et puis les enjeux
énergétiques une partie d'un pays qui
n'est pas totalement se développer aux
États-Unis d'Amérique la Californie
vient de restreindre les charges aux
heures de pointe donc alors que le
réseau n'est pas sollicité par un 100%
électrique pour le moment aux États-Unis
d'Amérique donc énormément d'hypothèques
j'entends bien ce qu'il se dit sur Tesla
c'est l'anti modèle l'anti modèle
précisément de ce vers quoi l'on cherche
à accéder c'est à dire une mobilité
généralisée ouverte très largement
popularisé et démocratique je veux dire
par là que Tesla est entier républicain
dans le sens où
l'enjeu c'est vraiment cette chose
publique qu'il s'agit de nourrir d'une
mobilité qui soit accessible à chacun y
compris au ruraux or les super chargeurs
Tesla sont dans la France utile dans la
France des corridors dans la France très
fréquentée des mégapoles en aucun cas le
reste du territoire n'intéresse est-ce
que c'est cela le contrat républicain de
la mobilité du 21e siècle que le
président Macron avait énergie
enthousiasme mondial et il fait ce
qu'ils peuvent finalement mais est-ce
que c'est cela que l'on propose
véritablement aux Français je pense que
là il y a quand même un problème de de
conscience politique et géopolitique
qu'il faudrait élargir et ne plus
raisonner comme un poisson rouge ou une
grenouille verte alors il y a pas que
Tesla il y a aussi il y a aussi des des
grands des grands opérateurs français
afin d'être par exemple de marque de de
l'agroalimentaire qui décide d'implanter
des bornes sur les sur les sur les
parkings de ces supermarchés
il y a beaucoup d'initiatives quand même
pour essayer de démocratiser un peu le
l'accès à la l'électricité et au bornes
électriques bien sûr on en est vraiment
à commencer en disant que on avait pris
du retard ce un modèle de société moi
j'aimerais bien vous entendre tous les
deux aussi là-dessus
la décision européenne finalement c'est
une façon de prolonger le modèle de du
tout auto du et qui nous plaît à nous à
automobile il est là ce modèle c'est
peut-être parce qu'il nous plaît vous
êtes pas d'accord non non d'abord
plusieurs choses on a une offre
aujourd'hui de véhicules électriques qui
part de la petite citadine à SUV des
grosses berlines etc dans une certaine
mesure je reprends la la phrase de
Montebourg que je trouvais sympathique
on va peut-être vers la voiture
populaire propre c'est pas impossible
tous les constructeurs européens sont en
train de construire une voiture
populaire propre écologique alors
aujourd'hui elle est effectivement un
peu cher chez nous elle est encore à
17000 euros avec le bonus déduit donc
c'est beaucoup à mon avis elle peut se
vendre beaucoup moins cher dans les
années à venir et surtout ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est aujourd'hui qui
achète des voitures électriques parce
que pour la plupart de ce qu'on connaît
dans les je parle de voiture neuve c'est
principalement les flottes d'entreprise
pour pas loin de 30% du marché c'est pas
rien et ça veut dire que là quand vous
avez une voiture électrique vous la
rechargez toute la journée au bureau
enfin dans le parking de l'entreprise on
est d'accord et puis les autres c'est
qui alors faut savoir que qui achète
aujourd'hui une voiture neuve c'est
principalement les gens de 50 60 ans
souvent des gens qui ne sont plus dans
la relation de missiles travaillent que
nous connaissons alors qu'est-ce qui
change et ben c'est tous ces modèles-là
alors on est dans une difficulté à court
terme en tout cas c'est que le marché de
l'occasion concernant électrique et
malheureusement très pauvre aujourd'hui
on est d'accord puis les gens vont pas
acheter des dernières électriques et ont
deux trois ans parce qu'elles sont déjà
plus performantes donc on cherche du
meilleur on cherche du plus performant
le modèle oui je crois qu'il est en
train de changer moi je crois je crois
d'abord parce qu'il y a véritablement
une offre de mobilité extraordinaire
qu'elle soit publique ou privée il y a
extraordinairement il y a beaucoup
d'offres dans les mégapoles partout
ailleurs dans la campagne dans les dans
les ciseaux plus rurales vous avez quand
même beaucoup aujourd'hui de nouveaux
modes des modes de covoiturage des modes
d'autopartage je pense pense
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont encore un peu
alors je dis pas que c'est généraliste
peut apporter l'électrique elle a ça moi
j'ai travaillé sur l'usage des batteries
et ça peut être intéressant à relever
parce qu'aux États-Unis on a des
expérimentations très intéressantes sur
ce qu'on appelle les smart grid
c'est-à-dire qu'on va utiliser notre
batterie le soir si elle est pleine et
bien tout simplement éventuellement pour
du chauffage pour de l'eau chaude mais
on peut aussi la céder à son voisin on
peut imaginer que ce ne soit pas moi
usagé qu'il utilise mais quelqu'un
d'autre et là on retrouve peut-être des
communautés des solidarités qu'on avait
un peu oublié je dire ça c'est pas du
tout exclure comme modèle de
développement de sa voiture oui tu es à
coup on peut imaginer que notre batterie
n'a pas seulement un usage de véhicule
ce sera à mon avis c'est pour demain ça
c'est très rapide c'est déjà quasiment
fait dans certains endroits alors on
reste sur l'expérience facile à retirer
facile à partager utilisable dans des
usages domestiques ou autres et surtout
céder à quelqu'un d'autre alors
justement et ça on reste dans cette dans
un modèle parce que vous nous dites ok
les voitures électriques grosso modo
sauf si on les utilise très longtemps et
que elle pèsent pas trop lourd elles ont
un bilan carbone qui est pas qui est pas
suffisant mais les voitures thermiques
c'est pas non plus une solution de les
garder donc c'est quoi le modèle quoi
est-ce qu'on arrête on interdit la
voiture dans les centres-villes point
barre ou alors on la partage parce qu'il
y a aussi ça parce qu'il y a de la
possession d'une voiture à l'usage donc
le fait de la partager une voiture et
mets d'autant moins de de cochonneries
dans l'air et utilise d'autant moins la
voirie qu'elle utilisait plus souvent
par un plus grand nombre de gens pour ça
qu'un taxi c'est pour ça qu'une voiture
de location c'est pour ça qu'un
semi-remorque au kilomètre transporté ou
kilomètre parcourus et au kilo
transporté et mais infiniment moins
qu'une voiture toute seule qui
globalement l'essentiel de son temps est
au parking donc effectivement c'est un
changement d'imaginaire avec la voiture
électrique généralisée même dans l'idéal
d'un réseau qui est fait pour elle on ne
pourra plus faire la même chose que l'on
fait avec une voiture essence se posera
la question vous l'avez dit se posera la
question d'une différence
territorial entre les gens des villes
entre les gens de la campagne pourquoi
parce que en ville il va se développer
forcément grâce à la densité de
population et grâce au budget des villes
danses comme Paris qui est plus
importantes qu'une commune on aura plein
de bornes partout et à la campagne vous
n'aurez rien du tout hors à la campagne
la même interdiction va se prolonger
enfin c'est complètement stupide
d'interdire les véhicules diesel en 2035
à la campagne parce que ces véhicules
sont utilisés longtemps ces véhicules
sont utilisés un régime moteur suffisant
pour que les filtres à particules
fonctionnent c'est pas là où est la
pollution la pollution elle est en ville
donc véhicule électrique en ville oui
vécu à la campagne franchement j'en vois
pas l'intérêt et qui va acheter des
véhicules en ville comme Jérôme
fourquelle dit
entre entre deux villes c'est la c'est
la civilisation de la Dacia la Dacia ça
coûte pas cher une voiture électrique ça
coûte très cher coûte encore peut-être
il y a un deuxième imaginaire qui est à
crocodile on achète une voiture pour
partir en vacances la voiture elle est
dimensionnée pour la seule fois où on
part en vacances trois semaines à alors
que la voiture elle devrait dimensionner
pour le trajet habituel pour le trajet
habituel une Zoé suffit or on n'achète
pas une voiture électrique pour ça on
achète une voiture électrique pour
partir en vacances donc on achète un SUV
pour lequel les besoins électriques sont
énormes et la prime écologique est alors
catastrophique on va parler des villes
tout de suite qui évidemment s'en
partent pas de depuis deux mois depuis
longtemps de cet enjeu de la mobilité
électrique Mathias vous pouvez nous nous
rejoindre bonsoir Mathias ce soir vous
allez nous présenter ce que l'on appelle
les aides fe absolument les zones
affaiblissement c'est bien ça alors
c'est dispositifs sont institués par
l'État depuis 2015 le principe et simple
il concerne des zones délimitées
géographiquement dans lesquelles les
véhicules les plus polluants ne peuvent
circuler qu'à des horaires restreints
alors vous allez me dire comment on
catégorise les véhicules les plus
polluants et bien grâce à la vignette
critères 6 catégories de 0 pour les
véhicules électriques un pour les
hybrides les véhicules au gaz ou les
essences les plus récents puis deux
trois quatre ou cinq pour les diesels
construit avant 2000 alors quels
agglomérations sont déjà concernées
aujourd'hui alors pour le moment
l'Hexagone compte une dizaine parmi
lesquels le Grand Paris Lyon Rouen
Grenoble ou encore Strasbourg des villes
qui devraient prochainement être
rejoints par beaucoup d'autres puisque
nos voix une loi votée pardon en août
2021 rang obligatoire la mise en place
d'une ZFE pour toutes les agglomérations
de plus de 150 000 habitants avant le 31
décembre 2024 dernière ville en date
Marseille depuis le 1er septembre
dernier mais qui va bénéficier d'une
période de tolérance jusqu'à la fin de
l'année et c'est important parce que là
cette transition elle est souvent mal
vécue ou mal comprise il y a un enjeu de
santé publique et bien absolument Thomas
puisque selon santé publique santé
publique France pardon on attribuerait
40 000 décès prématurés à une exposition
durable aux particules fines alors il
s'agit donc bien d'une question sérieuse
peut-être pas assez prise au sérieux
d'ailleurs dans les plus hautes sphères
puisque après une première amende en
août 2021 l'état vient d'être à nouveau
condamné à notamment de cette fois de 20
millions d'euros c'est un record pour
n'avoir pas fait respecter les normes
européennes en matière de qualité de
l'air alors la plus haute juridiction de
notre pays a reconnu des améliorations
dans la durée mais estime que la
situation reste fragile ou mauvaise dans
plusieurs zones merci Mathias pour ces
détails donc sur les aides à faible
émission Mathieu flonneau est-ce que
finalement
aujourd'hui dans dans l'état du marché
de la voiture électrique c'est cette
décision c'est à des feux
sont pas une machine à interdire les
centres-villes au plus pauvres de nos
concitoyens et c'est une évidence ce qui
vient d'être dit adossé à la discussion
qu'on a eu à l'instant sur la sélection
du territoire
ainsi ta réfléchir vraiment sans naïveté
au sujet parce que le mouvement des
gilets jaunes il est devant nous c'est à
dire que cette Jacquerie qui était aussi
due à des questions routières on va la
voir apparaître très violemment à partir
du moment où théoriquement les lois qui
viennent d'être énoncées interdisent à
70% du parc l'accès à certaines zones du
territoire j'entends bien que les
métropoles ont des offres même avec des
effets d'aubaine incroyables de mobilité
ce n'est pas le cas des mobilités
orphelines des territoires périphériques
de cette France que parfois on ne peut
pas voir parce qu'elle vote mal de se
croire et donc il y a vraiment un sujet
là qui est devant nous et j'attire aussi
votre attention sur un point c'est à
dire que cette soutenabilité cette
robustesse du système électrique il faut
quand même l'envisager en dehors de la
voiture particulière parce qu'on parle
de la culture routière on parle de la
culture du transport routier on parle
des ravitaillements qui étaient
indispensables pendant la période covid
on a mesuré la dépendance à ton bien
mesuré même en temps calme qui ne
reviendront probablement pas élaguer en
Ukraine est un des événements parmi
d'autres qui nous attendent dans les
années à venir on ne reviendra pas à une
situation calme apaisée autrement dit
devant toutes ces crises est-ce que
c'est pas un saut dans l'inconnu que de
vouloir véritablement à toute force et
légalement imposer système on n'est pas
à l'abri je pense du Grand refus chez
les transporteurs routiers chez les
usagers qui mènent sont des taxis ou
d'autres qui pour lesquelles
l'automobile est un objet de travail on
parle pas là d'une possession
individuelle de luxe sauf que à terme on
n'aura pas des des l'offre puisque les
constructeurs sont tous en train d'y
passer l'offre n'existera pas je reste
sur la question de de ceux qui peuvent
se payer finalement une voiture
électrique avec la la proposition du
prénom République de ces voitures en
électrique en leasing à 100 euros par
mois c'est pas encore proposé donc ça
veut dire que ça doit pas être si simple
à mettre en place c'est quoi c'est l'une
des solutions c'est une des solutions
oui c'est vrai il y a aussi le bonus le
bonus qui est quand même monté à 7000
euros par véhicule sur les petits
véhicules parce que sur les grosses
interdit par exemple vous achetez une
Tesla vous pouvez pas bénéficier d'un
bonus pareil oui non mais tout à fait
tout à fait alors maintenant je sais pas
je pense en même temps quand on achète
une voiture électrique euh il faut
raisonner dans le temps parce que le
raisonnement à court terme est compliqué
l'achat effectivement est onéreux mais
ce qu'il faut quand même souligner
certains constructeurs le font pas
suffisamment c'est que l'usage du
véhicule l'utilisation et en terme de
coûts
alors où l'on parle
on raisonne en terme de de kilomètres
bien vous faites quand même un plein de
enfin plein si on peut parier en ces
termes-là de 300-400 km pour à peine 15
ou 20 euros donc par rapport à la
facture
Mathieu l'évoquer tout à l'heure la
perte de taxes pour l'État elle est elle
est elle est tout sauf anodine donc je
pense que l'État va trouver à nos
systèmes de taxation c'est en général se
fait pas trop de soucis ils arrivent
toujours à rebondir un peu donc je pense
que on devrait y arriver à trouver notre
fiscalité mais après la question c'est
que aujourd'hui on raisonne avec un
bouclier tarifaire concernant
effectivement le prix de l'énergie enfin
électrique qu'est-ce qu'il en sera dans
quelques mois dans quelques temps ça
c'est une question quand même parce que
véritablement l'usage les coûts d'usage
sont très peu élevés et il faut savoir
aussi parce que ça c'est gros problème
de la filière c'est que vous n'avez pas
de réparation donc les garagistes les
réparateurs etc vont se retrouver quand
même sans emploi enfin à se reconvertir
en faisant autre chose à part l'usure
des pneus des pneumatiques moi j'utilise
quand même de l'électrique depuis un
moment je vois bien si une voiture qui
me coûte quasiment rien donc c'est une
vraie question alors c'est peut-être mal
vendu quelque part c'est à dire que on
raisonne en coût immédiat qui est une
assortir une somme importante mais il
faudrait raisonner sur 5 ou 10 ans
puisqu'une batterie dure environ 10 ans
aujourd'hui en durée de vie
ça rejoint un peu la démonstration que
vous faisiez je vous propose juste un
extrait d'un rapport de l'ADEME l'Agence
de la transition écologique qui date
d'il y a quelques jours rapport du 12
octobre dernier qui justement comparait
voiture électrique voiture thermique sur
l'ensemble de sa durée de vie une
voiture électrique roulant en France à
un impact carbone 2 à 3 fois inférieur à
celui d'un modèle similaire thermique
alors là dans les conditions à condition
que sa batterie soit de capacité
raisonnable inférieur à 60 kilowattheure
et avec une batterie de taille
supérieure l'invite l'intérêt
environnemental n'est pas garanti donc
ou ne pas garant c'est le terme des
employés batterie inférieure à 60 kWh
c'est une Peugeot 208 ou une Renault
Mégane vraiment à son grand maximum
voilà c'était pour pas vite pour pas
trop la solliciter donc c'est vraiment
une façon de l'utiliser il faut presque
une pédagogie de la conduite électrique
il faut apprendre à conduire électrique
c'est pas faux allez nous reste un peu
moins de de 10 minutes dans ce débat je
voudrais vraiment qu'on puisse consacrer
du temps la question de la souveraineté
c'est vraiment un enjeu majeur aussi
autour de cette question du passage au
tout électrique notamment sur les
batteries sur les les métaux rares qui
servent à les fabriquer question
évoquées d'ailleurs par le Président de
la République c'était au Mondial de
l'Auto ce lundi
il y a 5 ans quand je disais on va
développer l'électrique on me disait à
juste titre toutes les batteries
viennent d'Asie
maintenant on a développé 3 giga Factory
en France maintenant il faut réussir à
ce que ce qui est en amont de ces
batteries
soit fait en France sourcer ou sécurisé
alors il y a certains métaux étaient
rares que je n'aura pas en totalité sur
notre sol il faut qu'on le sécurise
qu'on sécurise le sourcing d'autres ont
les a pour qu'on puisse les exploiter et
qu'on donne de la visibilité sur le long
terme il faut qu'on développe aussi le
recyclage qui permettra d'améliorer
notre souveraineté en la matière alors
sur les giga Factory c'est vrai il y a
effectivement une filière des batteries
qui est en train de se mettre en place
en France et en Europe mais il reste la
question de ses métaux notamment lithium
c'est ça c'est avec denrées
dans le sous-sol français
pas grand chose pour l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est pour l'essentiel le
lithium c'est trois entreprises
chinoises des américaines et une
chilienne à peu près
d'énormes mines en Australie en France
en Europe on est très pauvre le lithium
et pas un métal rare du tout il est
abondant dans beaucoup d'endroits mais
il est mal localisé donc se pose la
question effectivement du recyclage mais
pas du recyclage seulement des batteries
c'est du recyclage de toutes les
batteries qui est dans tous nos
appareils électriques qui est mal fait
faut savoir que recycler du lithium ça
consomme beaucoup d'énergie et encore
une fois quand on fait le bilan
écologique carbone globale quand on
consomme de l'énergie pour aller
recycler un matériau ben le bilan est
pas forcément
ça veut dire que même en si on essaye de
créer une économie circulaire autour de
la batterie on pourra très difficilement
récupérer le lithium qui on peut le
récupérer mais un coût écologique un
coût énergétique est important dans ce
que je dis est simplement c'est que il y
a quelques quelques mines de lithium à
creuser en France et en Europe mais ça
représentera pas grand chose par rapport
aux besoins Daniel altias les Américains
viennent d'annoncer des mesures
protectionnistes sur les les voitures
électriques
ils peuvent veulent permettre c'est à
dire que ils ont pas de lithium sur leur
sol mais ils ont des partenaires qui
peuvent leur en fournir c'est ça c'est
quoi l'histoire c'est clair que leur
marché n'est pas comparable au nôtre
absolument pas ils peuvent se permettre
des mesures protectionnistes pour nous
c'est plus complexe quand même c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué alors eux ils
sont dépendants très largement de la
Chine pour un certain nombre de
composants et pour évidemment les
minerais ça c'est sûr faut savoir aussi
que si on achète aussi du lithium en
Chine c'est parce que le niveau de
raffinerie est quand même le meilleur du
monde donc c'est pour nous effectivement
une un sourcing extrêmement intéressant
mais alors en même temps ce qu'il faut
pas oublier quand on parle de production
parce que c'est bien les gigas Factory
etc bon c'est génial enfin on fait quand
même tous pratiquement que de
l'assemblage je veux dire on ne peut pas
parler de production il faut parler
d'assemblage on assemble des matériaux
qu'on va acheter à droite à gauche en
Corée en Chine etc les Américains font
quasiment pareil ils ont très peu
d'autonomie d'autonomie de production
enfin je veux dire ils vivent pas dans
un système autarcique loin de là ceci
dit ils ont un marché gigantesque ils
ont quelques avances en Californie dans
certains états en particulier sur le
véhicule autonome on connaît qui
aujourd'hui a quand même fait 12
millions de kilomètres ce qui est pas
rien alors ils ont quelques niches comme
ça technologiques très avancées qui leur
permet d'avoir de l'aisance mais grosso
modo on est quasiment égalité ils
peuvent se permettre effectivement des
axes protectionnistes nous je pense que
ce serait beaucoup plus difficile et oui
imaginez que la batterie de demain ou
d'après demain sera sans lithium sera
avec un nouveau métal ou c'est
impensable alors il y a une technologie
concurrente qui est compliquée alors moi
je suis en train de m'y intéresser assez
fortement je sais quelques centrales il
y a eu beaucoup de travaux là-dessus
c'est hydrogène
c'est peut-être à ça
parce que c'est vrai que les Japonais
qui nous souhaitent surtout pas être
dépendant des Chinois on connaît
l'histoire eux ils ont mis des milliards
sur la table et c'est le gouvernement
qui aide ces constructeurs à mettre un
plan hydrogène et l'hydrogène vert on
parle pas d'hydrogène gris bleu etc bon
il y a tout des nuances à apporter ils
ont gêne vert c'est vraiment l'hydrogène
qui va être qui va être réalisé à partir
des énergies renouvelables c'est-à-dire
le solaire le thermique etc à partir
d'hydrolyse et là il y a une solution
alternative un problème de batterie
merci enfin disons différemment mais en
plus petite en plus petit volume en plus
petite quantité d'accord donc on n'est
pas dans la batterie unique comme on a
de véhicules électriques classiques là
on est sur un autre champ c'est aussi la
taille des réservoirs et la et leur
protection voilà la longueur
pour l'instant c'est de réserver aux
véhicules utilitaires en tout cas c'est
c'est l'option prise
une option prise par les par les
constructeurs donc là si on est en train
de de décrire pour que ça fonctionne il
faudrait qu'on qu'on achète tous des
petites voitures électriques d'accord et
que on accepte de les recharger au
milieu de la nuit est-ce qu'il y a une
alternative bon on se dit de toute façon
la décision européenne a été prise les
constructeurs ils y vont tous on va je
vois mal comment dans dans 5 ans
pourraient leur dire vous faites
demi-tour offre à main pour reprendre
une autre direction est-ce qu'il y a une
alternative pour vous non très
probablement pas mais toujours est-il
que faut pas se bercer de de naïveté et
puis d'illusion technologique qui
n'apporteront pas des solutions qui sont
plutôt dans les usages en effet et là il
y a des progrès à faire mais ces progrès
sont aussi à la mesure du reniement de
liberté que l'on va imposer aux classes
les moins aisées
tout à l'heure qu'on prenne conscience
que finalement on a peut-être pas besoin
d'être d'avoir une voiture à soi de
posséder
pour partir en week-end ou pour partir
en vacances
Denise midose alt à la croissance etc
les l'écologie politique profonde qui se
font dans ces périodes là remet en
question le modèle de la voiture on est
60 ans après il n'a fait que croître et
embellir et aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut
quoi c'est ce que vous nous dites c'est
ce que j'ai dit
mais attention parce que c'est très
sérieux l'individualisme c'est très
sérieux la liberté individuelle on va là
quand même devant des sociétés qui de
plus en plus traces de plus en plus
limite et de plus en plus s'oriente vers
le low cost alors j'entends bien car un
renouvellement de génération c'est très
enfin c'est plus facile de faire
accepter une génération qui n'a pas
connu autre chose les restrictions mais
attention
l'alcool fort un goût l'automobilisme
ancien avait un goût tout ceci est en
train de passer on peut le regretter à
certains égard même s'il faisait les
progrès parce que j'entends
l'intimilation écologique sur les morts
prématurés par l'air vicié c'est parfait
ce qui est factuel également c'est la
réduction des nuisances automobiles ce
qui est factuel également c'est tout à
fait factuel vous avez raison ce qui est
factuel également c'est l'amélioration
du système automobile par exemple sur
les morts violentes par accident de la
route on est passé de 18000 à 3000 donc
il y a des marges de manœuvre il y a des
marges d'amélioration de ce système il y
a des marges de civilisation de
l'automobilisme et ça existe beaucoup de
responsabilités collectives alors je
voudrais vous entendre Daniel Assia sur
le justement la question que vous l'avez
abordé la question de génération oui
est-ce que la nouvelle génération est
moins je sais pas quel terme employé
mais accro à l'automobile que finalement
la nôtre
moi alors peut-être évidemment je ne
vais pas réduire le spectre de
générationnel à simplement des étudiants
des grandes écoles etc bon je voudrais
pas parce que ce serait ce serait un peu
bon surtout pas donc c'est vrai mais
quand même il y a une génération qui
émerge d'abord qui a une conscience
écologique incroyable
la question climatique est une question
centrale pour eux et qui ont grandi
parfois dans des grands centres urbains
oui non même pas ne nécessiter de
voiture moi je vais vous dire moi
j'avais une chair de recherche chez
Peugeot pendant 10 ans le patron de
Peugeot à l'époque me disait vous allez
pouvoir m'expliquer comment mes deux
garçons c'était pas trop de Peugeot
n'ont jamais passé leur permis bon
d'accord alors moi je disais bah écoutez
voilà c'est une autre génération etc
mais une fois qu'on a dit une autre
génération je peux vous dire quand même
qu'il y a un exemple qui est très
intéressant moi j'enseigne à Pékin à
centrale Pékin et bien les jeunes sont
tous en électriques alors comment ça se
passe tout simplement parce que la Chine
est passée en retard sur la voiture
thermique donc elles ont d'accéder à
l'électrique mais alors la progression
elle est intéressante il commence par le
vélo électrique ensuite le scooter
électrique puis quand il commence à
s'installer avec une famille avec un
deux enfants naturellement ils achètent
une voiture ils vont l'acheter
électrique ils ont connu que ça alors
vous allez me dire c'est un peu
particulier c'est un peu spécifique mais
on va trouver aussi en France en Europe
en Europe des gens qui ont aussi ce
réflexe là parce que sa réflexe
écologique et que du coup la voiture
l'usage la propriété en tant que telle
je pense quand même qu'elle est remise
en partie en question je pense merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler les titres
de vos livres Daniel Attias la
révolution de l'automobile vers un
nouveau paradigme de l'électromobilité
publié chez Springer Matthieu flonot
votre livre c'est en tous sens circulé
partagé sécurisé une histoire des
équipements de la route aux éditions
loubatier a pu signal cette exposition
permis de conduire au Musée des arts et
métiers que qui vient de démarrer qui
est là pour plusieurs semaines et
vous m'avez signalé l'ouverture et qui a
l'air passionnante Frédéric denré votre
livre rencontre avec des écolos
remarquables chez de la chaux et Nestlé
à très bientôt sur ce plateau merci
encore